hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in the course of his Ponce's these
unfinished work Paschal gives us a
really effective argumentative or
rhetorical strategy for telling people
they're wrong in such a way that they
can actually hear us in the French and
in the English translation it's
expressed in terms of correcting others
he says when we wish to correct with
advantage when we want to correct in
such a way that something good is going
to come out of it then we should follow
this strategy now many people may balk
at hearing this term correction because
they have negative associations with it
I you know don't correct me that that's
being mean to me in some way or
patronizing or disrespectful but it
doesn't really have that sense and if
you think about correction in general
what does it mean it means to set things
right and so for correcting a person's
mindset or their information or their
views on things we're hopefully not just
trying to be a jerk to them but we're
actually directing them towards what is
true something away from what they think
is true which may be false and towards
what is actually true and true not just
in a speculative or theoretical sense or
you know banal and factual sense but but
practical in terms of how they ought to
be regulating their life what they ought
to be worrying themselves to how to
prioritize all of those things are
matters in which we and other people do
in fact often require correction so the
fundamental question here is how best to
get someone to see where they've got
something wrong and paschal suggest that
we don't begin with saying Oh buddy
you've got things wrong we don't begin
by simply saying you're off base you're
mistaken
instead we
do something else before we even open
our mouths he says we have to notice
what side Cote in French meaning like a
bank or a side of something you know for
example you are seeing this chalk from
the opposite side that I am not really a
lot of change in the chalk right but
you're seeing a blue book I'm seeing
white pages now you're seeing white
pages I'm seeing a blue binder those are
different sides of things and when it
comes to all sorts of phenomena that we
might take positions on and be right or
wrong about there are many sides you
know a relationship for example you know
I think the relationship is
fundamentally of this sort but the other
person who is in that same relationship
thinks it's a different kind of
relationship when we get into conflicts
I think I was in the right and you drew
first blood with a terrible thing you
said and you think precisely the same
but change the people around on your
side so there can be very different
sides of different things we need to
notice what side the other person is on
rather than just simply pushing our own
point of view we need to extend them a
certain kind of charity or
open-mindedness or however you want to
put it the capacity to put ourselves in
somebody else's place and see things not
necessarily physically through their
eyes but at least try to see things the
way that they might see them we might
not be successful in this but if we
don't make the effort we're definitely
not going to be successful he also says
that if we do this we're going to notice
that there is some sort of truth from
that point of view from that side they
may not be completely correct as a
matter of fact they may be off base
about many things it could be that the
truth that they have on their side is
what we might call
an imaginary truth if we imagine that
things are like this or a hypothetical
truth if we imagine that all these
things are as the person perceives them
then it would be true that that you know
this is the case as the person does
believe we have to be able to grasp
whatever measure of truth there is on
their side why because that allows us to
connect with them that allows us to then
admit that truth to that person so it's
not just about being empathetic it's not
just about seeing their point of view
Pascal says you have to actually say to
that person okay I get you in that
respect I think that you actually do
have some things right here's the things
where I agree with you here's the things
where maybe I don't agree with you but I
can at least see how it appears that way
to you here's the things I need to think
about more because maybe you actually
are better informed about this than I am
and if you do this you're treating the
other person as if they have some sort
of seat at the table as if they are on
some level your epistemological equal as
if they get to have a real conversation
with you as a partner once you've done
that
Pascal says then you can also start
bringing up other sides to it and you
can start bringing up the other sides
from which what they're saying is
actually false you could you could do
this in multiple ways you can say look
you're saying this is always the case
but if you look at it from this point of
view there are exceptions to what you're
saying so what would you be arguing in
that case you'd be saying you're making
a universal rule it admits of a lot of
exceptions so it's not really a
universal rule it looks that way to you
because you haven't seen these
exceptions over here or you might say I
get what you're saying I understand why
things seem or feel
way that they do to you from the point
of view that you're coming at it but if
we look at it from this point of view
the actions that you think are noble are
actually self-centered or are malicious
or if you look at it from this point of
view the argument that you think I
started maybe began way back here with
something that you said and if you've
already recognized where the other
person has things right where they they
have a case that that's plausible and
you've acknowledged it then they'll be
more willing to hear you say where
they've got it wrong not necessarily
completely some people are just jerks
and won't listen to anything that you
say and if you make any admission that
they have some things right they will
take that as being completely right but
Pascal is talking about most people how
you can deal with other people
reasonably so you reveal the other sides
from which they've got things wrong
they've left things out they've not
taken something into consideration that
needs to be talked about what's the
effect of this here's where it gets very
interesting Paschal makes a distinction
here she says that the person realizes
that he or she is not mistaken the
French word for that is Pompeii
you know deceived they are not deceived
they're not a dummy they're not off base
entirely they're not just an idiot but
that they they didn't notice all the
different sides so there's a distinction
here between being like totally wrong
totally off base just a you know a fool
and missing something in the situation
which then you could take account of and
somehow incorporate into what you do in
fact have right or perhaps used to
modify what you've got right there is a
big difference between these if you tell
somebody that they're completely wrong
where do they have to start from they
can either accept your point
of you in a you know presented in a
rather despotic or tyrannical way a very
controlling way at the very least even
if it's done in a sort of you know this
is for the best
I just want to give you the correct view
on things you know if you're in a very
patronizing way they're they're stuck
either they accept it or they're an
idiot but if you're working with it in
the other way that paschal is suggesting
and you're saying listen I want you to
keep on believing these things over here
you're right about that but these things
over here you also need to take account
of them and and maybe if you bring them
all together you'll compromise on a few
of the things that you're committed to
right now that's a very different point
of view that's actually much more likely
to be successful because again you're
treating the person as an equal in some
sense as somebody who you value somebody
who has thoughts of his or her own so
the upshot of this is that the person
won't be offended he says they won't
take offense at missing some side of it
why not
because we all miss something right so
we need other people to help fill us in
about something that's why we read books
in the first place because we're not
self-sufficient when it comes to
understanding things but he does say
nobody likes being mistaken again the
French word Pompey decieved having
gotten things entirely wrong he says
perhaps that arises from the fact that
human beings can't naturally see
everything and that they naturally can't
err on the side that they look at but
they will err in other sides he says
something else that that contributes to
this picture a little bit later he tells
us people are generally better persuaded
by the reasons which they have
themselves discovered than by those
which have come into
minds of others so how can that process
of discovery take place that doesn't
mean that they have to like totally
figure it out on their own but they have
to be allowed the opportunity to see
what they missed out on and to you might
say take ownership of it and then try to
incorporate it into the rest of the
ideas or thoughts or propositions or
however you want to put it that they are
working with so if you adopt this sort
of strategy it's not gonna work every
single time and it shouldn't be done in
a purely cynical way this is not meant
to be sort of the sandwich if you're not
familiar with that rhetorical device
that's when you give some negative
feedback is as the meat in between two
bits of positive feedback you know
you're really doing a great job talking
with clients now I wanted to talk to you
about the fact that you need to shower a
lot more everybody is complaining how
much you stink at work but on the other
hand your spreadsheets are amazing
that's kind of artificial that's kind of
cynical right Paschal is not suggesting
you do anything like that instead he's
he's suggesting that you adopt this as a
kind of attitude towards other people if
you do this he doesn't mention this here
but if you do this
and you approach other people in this
way it's also going to have a positive
effect on your own point of view as you
start to realize the sides that you
yourself are leaving out when you are
staking claims when you are expressing
your point of view when you are telling
other people that this is the way things
are and that can be a good thing all
around so this is a very useful strategy
contained in Pascal's Ponce's and you
might want to give it a try
you